bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches les
missions économiques sans aucune limite
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler des états unis face à la crise
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ces caches comme
de nombreux pays et les états unis ont
été frappés par le cos vide des 19
s'en sont suivis des manifestations
massives anti raciste et contre les
violences policières
et si ces événements avait redistribué
les cartes sur la scène internationale
jusqu'à quel point les états unis ont
été fragilisés par ces crises quel
impact sur l'économie américaine ce sont
les questions auxquelles on tentera de
répondre dans cette émission
et pour cela nous serons en deuxième
partie avec sylvie matelly économistes
et directrice adjointe de l'iris
l'institut des relations internationales
et stratégiques
mais d'abord olivier on va commencer par
un état des lieux où en sont les états
unis ont fait le point avec le tiroir
cash d'antoine passe ici avec toutes les
crises qu'il traverse actuellement les
états unis perdent un peu de leur
hégémonie
si l image de ce que l'on a vécu après
les deux guerres mondiales
le visage du monde était amené à changer
il ya d'abord la pandémie selon les
bilans officiels
les etats unis sont aux premiers pays
touchés dans le monde
il compte aujourd'hui plus de 2 millions
de cas et près de 120 mille décès trump
tantôt alarmistes tantôt trop rassurant
ou a été et continue d'être fortement
critique
pour sa gestion de l'épidémie les états
unis paraissent donc affaibli face à
cette crise sanitaire en ayant échoué à
endiguer la pandémie sur leur territoire
pendant que de son côté la chine même si
son bilan officiel et bien souvent
remise en cause est allé jusqu'à
apporter de l'aide aux pays les plus
touchés en asie au moyen-orient et même
en europe
trump a également dû faire face à la
montée des manifestations anti racistes
sur le territoire américain
puis sur toute la planète dressant le
visage d'une amérique où le racisme est
toujours présent et ancrer le
contre-coup du soft power américain
négatif ou positif ce qui se passe
là-bas fini par se globaliser et après
un mandat de trump et son fameux america
first
autrement dit une amérique - tourner sur
le monde et plus vers elle même une
amérique du repli sur soi il ne serait
pas étonnant si la crise perdure que les
cartes de gaz géopolitique mondiale
finissent par être rebattues olivier on
vient de le voir les états unis sont
traversées par plusieurs secousses et
tout cela à moins de quelques mois de
l'élection présidentielle
vous viviez quel regard vous portez sur
la situation des états unis que l'on
vient d'évoquer dans le tiroir cache le
situation des états unis ils sont je
vous rappelle en période électorale
donc au mois de novembre il va y avoir
des élections présidentielles aux états
unis et donc ils sont aux modes de
on fait n'importe quoi sans aucune
limite pour pouvoir gagner les élections
vous avez 15 tweets par jour de monsieur
de monsieur trump vous avez des annonces
à droite et à gauche pour essayer de
faire en sorte que les choses ne
s'écroule pas avant juste avant les
élections
maintenant après sur ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis sur eux le mouvement black
matters c'est un moyen de détourner de
ce qui se passe réellement on prend un
fait divers si horrible soit il on prend
un fait divers qui est pas plus horrible
que probablement tout ce qui se passe
aux etats-unis à longueur de temps mais
dont on n'a pas le le la communication
et et on en fait quelque chose pour pour
en fait dirigé l'attention des
américains est d'ailleurs maintenant du
monde entier sur autre chose que les
vrais problèmes qui qui se passe dans
les économies et socialement en fait on
est en train que ce soit aux états unis
ou en france et même probablement dans
le reste de l'europe
on est en train finalement de ce
libaniser c'est à dire que vous avez
communauté contre communauté on n'a
jamais voulu régler les problèmes depuis
très très longtemps on est en train d'en
payer le prix
dans tous les pays et il faut souhaiter
que
on reprenne les choses en main et que ça
ne soit ça ne devienne pas comme le
liban ni économiquement ni socialement
parlant
merci olivier on passa tout de suite à
la deuxième partie de cette émission
et pour parler des états unis nous
sommes en liaison avec sylvie matelly
économistes et directrice adjointe de
l'iris l'institut des relations
internationales et stratégiques à sylvie
matelly bonjour bonjour merci à beaucoup
à d'avoir accepté notre invitation
bienvenus alors il est bien évidemment
trop tôt pour évaluer définitivement
l'impact de la crise liée aux qu'ovide
mais on a vu que les états unis avaient
été assez absent un finalement de la
scène internationale pendant cette
pandémie en avril à dernier donald trump
a même décidé de suspendre la
participation du pays à l oms
est-ce que selon vous l'ordre mondial
est en train d'être bouleversé l'ordre
mondial est en train d'être bouleversée
c'est le en train et être un petit peu
de trop parce que ça fait quand même un
certain temps ça fait plus d'une
vingtaine d'années qui s est vraiment
d'événements inattendus qui bouleverse
est fort dans mondial et je crois que le
repli sur soi dont on a déjà parlé des
états unis il part de ce constat en fait
du fait que les états unis ne pèse plus
comme avant se sont fait piquer une
partie où certains attributs de leur
leadership par un certain nombre
d'autres pays voir d'ailleurs deux
acteurs non étatiques et qu'il est temps
qu'il retrouve en ce en se recentrant
sur les leur intérêt qu'ils retrouvent
les attributs de ce leadership en tout
cas sans ce leadership les attributs de
leur puissance et de leur prospérité
donc on est vraiment dans cette logique
là et je ne crois pas le locaux vides 19
et les événements que nous venons de
vivre ne sont que kamerhe a de plus
dense est dans cette logique là reste à
savoir si ce repli sur soi va continuer
avec après les élections présidentielles
puisqu'on est en campagne alors rien ne
dit que donald trump ne sera pas réélu
s'il est réélu je pense qu'il va
amplifier encore la voilure sachant
qu'il a plus que quatre ans pour
imprimer sa marque et qu il ne se
privera pas d'exploiter ces quatre
années
mais très clairement on ne sait pas ce
que va être la politique du successeur
qui peut être dans la continuité
peut-être avec des méthodes un petit peu
moins violente et un petit peu moins
jusqu'au boutiste que celle de donald
trump mais on est on est dans le flou
absolu et de la même manière sur la
situation économique on évalue assez
bien en fait ce qui s'est passé pendant
la période de confinement ce qui s'est
passé avec cette épidémie de kobe
d'alors il ya quelques semaines on
pensait qu'elle était derrière nous on
se rend compte que c'est peut-être pas
tout à fait le cas et qu'il ya peut-être
encore des démos mois difficile à passer
mais la certitude elle est aux tables
sur le redémarrage des économies et on a
l'impression qu'actuellement ça
redémarre plus vite que prévu mais parce
que l'arrêt avait été tellement brutale
qu'on avait imaginé le pire
olivier une réaction à ce que vient de
dire s'il est ma télé non alors sur la
sur la reprise je m'inscris en faux
alors vous avez eu évidemment un effet
de rattrapage mais ça c'est c'est
toujours le l'effet mathématiques qui
est assez amusant quand vous dégringolé
de 70% vous perdez 70 points pour tomber
à 30
et quand vous remontez de 20 après 20 ça
vous paraît un chiffres délirants de
hausse sauf que ça fait six points de
plus par rapport à 30 donc vous êtes ça
on nous avait fait le coup sûr la grèce
aussi c'était assez amusant on
s'exclamer d'un d'une d'une reprise de
2% mais c'était une reprise de 2 % sur
sur un trick sur un pib qui avait déjà
plongé de plus de 60% donc
excusez moi mais là où on est loin de la
reprise alors évidemment vous avez vous
avez monsieur trump et vous avez
monsieur pauwels qui vous abreuve de
petites phrases en nous disant que ça y
est la grande la grande american power a
fonctionné et que ils ont même créé des
emplois pendant le confinement c'était
assez amusant donc il vous sortent un
chiffre qui est faux dont on sait qu'il
est faux qu'ils ont oublié 4,7 millions
de chômeurs mais il insiste un y
persiste parce que il faut que à tout
prix les marchés tiennent pour que
monsieur monsieur trump soirée lui donc
et qui que ce soit lui succédera
trouvera quand même une économie à
l'agonie aux états unis malheureusement
et ne pourra donc pas faire grand chose
mais on est dans le paraître on est dans
la communication il cela depuis un
moment on se fiche et il y a un certain
temps des chiffres annoncés par les
chinois en disant qu'il trafiquait leur
leurs chiffres et bien je vous
l'annonçais les états unis c'est pas
mieux alors sylvie métayer puisque
olivier évoque la chine on a vu d'un
point de vue géopolitique la chine venir
en aide aux européens comme l'italie par
exemple est-ce que la position de la
chine aujourd'hui sur l'échiquier
mondial pourrait être renforcé à part
cette crise au détriment des états unis
elle est la position de la chine est
renforcée non pas par cette crise mal a
renforcé depuis plusieurs années par la
croissance économique de la chine
même si les chiffres sont truquées ou
ont souvent été contestés il est
indiscutable que la chine est devenue en
quelques années la deuxième puissance
économique mondiale
en dix ans elle est passée delà de la
huitième à la à la deuxième puissance
économique du monde donc ça c'est une
réalité
et en plus avec une chine qui depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir de ce sujet mme
pitt veut se repositionner et se
projeter ce qui est assez nouveau dans
l'histoire économique et l'histoire
politique de ce pays
donc ça c'est une réalité reste à savoir
à présent ce qui est ce qui est certain
si on regarde contrairement à tout ce
qui a été dit ces dernières années ce
qui est certain c'est que les états unis
ont largement profité de l'essor de la
chine
et là aussi même les autorités
américaines et la politique de trump
aujourd'hui à contester sa et et sa
guerre commerciale bien content ccsa
pourtant quand vous regardez les
statistiques
si l'économie américaine s'est redressée
aussi rapidement après la crise de 2008
c'est en raison de sa politique
monétaire expansionniste dans le cas de
la de trump de la politique budgétaire
et des baisses d'impôts massives qu'il a
organisée mais aussi parce que la chine
portent l'économie américaine et que ce
sont les deux moteurs de l'économie
mondiale donc ça c'est une réalité
reste à savoir ce qu'il va sortir de
cette pandémie la chine ne redémarre pas
beaucoup plus vite que les états unis
les difficultés économiques sont réels
on est face à des crises
kiki sans précédent dans l'histoire
économique et donc il est difficile de
savoir si la chine va bénéficier non pas
ya effectivement des aspects qui relève
aussi la communication et d'une certaine
forme de communication de crise
il ya des aspects qui ont servi les
intérêts de la chine et qui ont permis
de positionner la chine et la mettre en
porte-à-faux par rapport à des états
unis qui était pas très habile dans leur
communication de crise c'est certain
mais la chine a commis aussi beaucoup
beaucoup d'erreurs en termes de
communication en termes de
positionnement et de réaction face à
cette pandémie de de convives 19 donc il
est aujourd'hui difficile de prendre du
recul et de savoir ce qu'il en restera à
l'issue de cette crise puisque vous
savez la communication une communication
cherche une autre et que les cartes sont
encore sur la table
olivier à la chine sans candidat
crédible pour prendre la place de leader
ça sera évidemment un candidat crédible
maintenant je vous rappelle que
récemment le mbr qui est toujours en
retarde de deux plusieurs années mais là
pour le coup il a il a essayé de
travailler un petit peu plus vite nous a
annoncé que le les etats-unis étaient en
récession avant le confinement
donc on a bien on a bien quelque chose
qui a été le co vide a été un
déclencheur a été un détonateur mais en
aucun cas mes responsables de la crise
qui étaient là et qui était là depuis
longtemps on l'a dit des milliers de
fois c'est pas en imprimant des billets
que vous relancer une économie donc est
hissé vous étiez en récession moi je
date la récession de la fin 2018 début
2019 aux états unis vous verrez qu'on y
viendra petit à petit quand le nbr fera
son boulot
alors avant de s'intéresser aux
conséquences de ces crises sur le plan
national sylvie matelly quel avenir
concrètement pour les états unis sur la
scène internationale comment peuvent-ils
pour reprendre vos propos de tout à
l'heure retrouver a les attributs de
leur lit
chip s'ils tentaient qu'il souhaite
retrouver les attributs de leur
leadership parce que dans l'histoire des
états unis
ce leadership américain est quand même
l'exception plutôt que la règle on a un
pays qui dans son histoire certes assez
courte a plutôt cherché à se protéger
cac a joué qu'à jouer sur la scène
internationale donc reste à savoir s'il
ya vraiment cette volonté la politique
étrangère est pas un sujet d'intérêt pas
un centre d'intérêt pour les américains
c'est pas un sujet d'ailleurs de débats
dans les campagnes électorales ont ça
vient très très tard dans la campagne
donc on est on est vraiment face à sète
hérault interrogation aujourd'hui de
savoir s'il ya cette volonté
ce qui est certain c'est que les états
unis sont très attachés à leur situation
économique qu'ils défendront leur place
de première puissance mondiale
mais ça c'est un leadership économique
c'est pas un leadership politique ou la
volonté de peser sur la scène
internationale et qui le défendrons par
tous les moyens
reste à savoir ce que seront ses moyens
dans le cas de donald trump on a vu que
ça pouvait aller très très loin guerre
commerciale et au delà peut-être la
question qui se pose également c'est là
que sera cette économie au sortir de
cette pandémie puisqu'on est encore dans
cette pandémie est là encore les
réactions américaines et les choix
politiques américains seront d'autant
plus violent que la crise sera forte
merci à sylvie matelly on remarque une
courte pause et on vient dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez on parle des états unis avec à
sylvie matelly économistes et directrice
adjointe de l iris alors olivier les
etats-unis sont entrés en récession en
février à dernier selon la définition du
bureau national de recherche économique
pour le n 10 heures il y a récession si
je cite l'activité économique répartis
sur l'ensemble de l'économie décline de
manière à significatifs pendant une
durée supérieure à plusieurs mois
visible dans le pib réel
le revenu réel l'emploi la production
industrielle et les ventes en gros et au
détail une définition à qui diffère donc
légèrement de celle qui fait foi en
europe notamment
juste avant le pays cumulait 128 mois
consécutif de croissance olivier lorsque
l'on est à la première puissance
mondiale la reprise peut-elle être aussi
rapide que la chute mais non mais
justement c'est bien c'est bien le
problème si vous voulez c'est que
aujourd'hui la plupart des économistes
et des stratégistes nous annonce des
reprise en v parce que c'est finalement
ce qu'ils ont connu le plus c'est à dire
avec une pente aussi aussi importante
que la descente donc une reprise assez
fort qui finalement en 2022 règle le
problème
il ne s'est rien passé et tout va bien
les plus audacieux quelques-uns se
disent on va trouver autre chose que le
v on va prendre une autre lettre et puis
là on est même arrivés pour certains à
la racine carrée
alors on en invente plein comme ça des
bébés des profils de reprise
et moi je voudrais vous en soumettre un
autre c'est le zen ça et la reprise en
est c'est à dire qu'il y avait pas de
croissance avant on descend de plusieurs
étages et on va recommencer avec papa
croissance
voilà ça peut être ça peut être une un
nouveau profil
ce qu'il faut vraiment se se dire je
pense que c'est on est à la fin d'un
d'un modèle
alors on essaie de le faire perdurer
mais on est à la fin d'un modèle qui
était le tout misé sur la dette tout
misé sur la monnaie et tout miser sur la
dette donc tout ne fonctionnait plus
qu'avec de la dette alors là on voit que
pour régler le problème on en rajoute
plein parce que c'est quand même
beaucoup plus drôle on sait que ça ne
fonctionne pas mais on va quand même
continuer à avoir les mêmes les mêmes
raisonnements et les mêmes les mêmes
actions que ce qu'on a toujours eu parce
que si on l'a toujours connue donc il
faut surtout pas utiliser son cerveau
pour essayer de trouver autre chose là
le problème c'est que on risque avec ce
cet impact qu vide de changer de modèle
est il que le monde d'après soit sans
mauvais jeu de mots différents du monde
d'avant en espérant qui sera moins pire
que le monde d'avant parce que sinon
c'est pas drôle
hélas si c'est un autre modèle vous
risquez fort en effet d'avoir un profil
en z c'est à dire vous ne reviendrai
jamais à au modèle d'avant vous ne
reviendrait jamais sur les niveaux
d'avant et donc il faudra réinventer les
choses sylvie matelly réaction aux
propos d'olivier oui alors je partage
cette idée qu effectivement on est dans
un an on est au bout d'un modèle est
qu'il faut il faut passer à autre chose
et effective et et les la question de la
dette la dette et la relance par la
dette ou par la création monétaire
c'est quelque chose qui a fonctionné
systématiquement et c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on se rabat sur ses cartes là ça a
fonctionné pourquoi ç'a fonctionné au
moins à court terme c'est-à-dire à court
terme reste à voir alors il n'y a qu'à
voir les états unis
quelques mois après des grosses crises
économiques ou financières l'économie
repartait et il y avait un semblant de
croissance est en tout cas des créations
d'emplois donc ça c'est une certitude
sauf qu'on le voit là on ne ça ne
fonctionne pas c'est que les dettes
s'accumulent sans qu'on n'ait jamais
aucun répit pour pouvoir les résoudre et
que finalement la crise suivante arrive
presque trop vite et qu'elle se elles
seules elles se multiplient ls succès de
plus en plus rapidement donc là c'est
certain
la question qui nous pousse aussi au
changement modèles au-delà de cette
dette
c'est la question de la lutte contre le
changement climatique c'est-à-dire à un
moment donné on se rend compte qu'on est
dans un modèle de gaspillage excessive
de démission et de pollution excessive
et que ça n'est pas tenable que ça des
effets pervers divers et variés la
pandémie nous questionne aussi sur la
mondialisation et notre façon de vivre
dans un monde d'interdépendance des
changes permanent de d'échangés de
contact permanent donc on a toutes ces
questions qui sont posées ces derniers
temps par certain nombre d'événements
auxquels on va devoir répondre
ce qui est certain en tout cas c'est que
si on parie autant et si on essaie
autant de relancer la croissance
économique c'est que fondamentalement on
sait on sait pas faire sans croissance
économique est ce que moi la leçon que
je tire de cette pandémie où on s'est
aperçu que l'on confie dans tout le
monde
ben casser la croissance mais enfin on
lutter contre les émissions de co2 et on
parvenait à lutter de manière quasi
instantanée contre le changement
climatique
donc ce que ce qui est apparu très
clairement c'est que ça on savait qu'on
n'allait pas il y avait on était sur
deux mondes qui était radicalement
opposés et que le passage d'un monde où
la croissance est indispensable un monde
où la croissance sera beaucoup plus
faible
ou en tout cas trouver ailleurs la
redistribution sera différente mais on
protégera en préservant mieux ce
l'environnement et ce qu'on a autour de
nous et est quelque part est une utopie
et qu'on n'a pas trouvé pour l'instant
les moyens et les mesures pour y
parvenir
espérons que les politiques de relance
qui seront mis en place dans les mois
prochains tenteront de trouver des
solutions et 30 tenteront d'innover en
la matière pour l'instant on voit pas
d'annoncés concrètes ce qui est certain
c'est que on est dans une période de
transition de transition énergétique de
transition écologique mais qu'on a pour
l'instant pas les clés pour définir le
nouveau monde
un mot sur l'emploi le taux de chômage
s'établit en mai
concerne à présent 13 3% de la
population active en mai l'or ce qui est
alors qu'ils n'ont concerné que 3 5% en
février
le chômage a tout de même baissé à
d'avril à mai et cela alors que les
analystes les plus pessimistes
envisagent et anto à 20% pour tenter de
limiter les dégâts
donald trump a décidé à le 22 juin de
jeu les allées carte verte est certes un
visa de travail jusqu'en 2021
selon un haut responsable américain à
cette pause devrait empêcher plus de 500
mille étrangers d'entrer sur le sol
américain et permettra de réserver leur
emploi à des américains alors olivier on
le sait avec vous trouvez très souvent
les chiffres du chômage sous-évaluée
pour autant avec ce genre de mesures le
pays peut-il rebondir rapidement
non mais c'est pas sous-évalué c'est un
énorme mensonge et c'est un énorme
mensonge en plus avoué dès le départ par
le bls c'est à dire par le bureau du
travail américain qui sort ce chiffre en
dix ans on a oublié 4,7 pour 4,7
millions de chômeurs donc votre chiffre
de 13 7
on le sait de qualité c'est sa part des
mesures au delà des chiffres est ce que
ce genre de mesures peuvent permettre
aux états unis de s'en sortir mais non
mais c'est important ce genre de schiste
parce que on raconte des conneries aux
gens c'est ça que ça veut dire c'est
c'est pas rien on ment effrontément et
on le sait donc c'est pas rien on ne
peut pas continuer à diffuser des
chiffres qui sont absolument faux
simplement parce que ça arrange monsieur
trump à ce moment là et ça arrange les
marchés parce que comme ça ça leur
permet de continuer à monter septième
sport après sur sûr c'est sur ces refus
de visage parce que honnêtement les
c'est pas ça qui va faire diminuer le
chômage
faut pas rêver arrêtons un petit peu de
2,2 d'emploi de ces décéda comme ça
c'est de la com on va dire on va fermer
les frontières et comme ça il n'y aura
pas de diminuer les d'immigration
clandestine et ça viendra pas rentrer
dans le chiffre du chômage
c'est se de la gueule du monde
c'est vraiment se de la gueule du
monde et ça vous l'avez aujourd'hui
malheureusement dans tous les pays c'est
à dire qu'on vous
annonce des choses qui sont parfaitement
fausse en vous mon temps en vous
regardant droit dans les yeux et en
prenant les gens pour des cons si vous
pensez que c'est de la com aussi est-ce
que c'est un moyen aussi pour trump qui
est en campagne d'utiliser certains
levier qui avait séduit sous l'ailé de
son électorat en 2016 tout à fait et c
c'est clairement c'est clairement de la
communication c'est clairement ce sont
clairement des effet d'annonce qui n'ont
absolument aucune efficacité parce que
les populations les populations
immigrées aux états unis les étrangers
qui viennent bosser aux états unis
viennent bosser dans des secteurs où
aucun américain ne veut travailler et on
l'a vu d'ailleurs on a vu les
inquiétudes quant donald trump est
arrivé au pouvoir en 2016 les
inquiétudes au texas en californie d'un
certain nombre de fermiers américains
qui se disait mais comment je vais
cultiver mes légumes ramasser mes fruits
vendanger mais vie si je n'ai pas cette
main d'oeuvre étrangère qui vient
réaliser ce travail
donc si vous fermez les frontières nous
on va être envahie dans la panade
très clairement c'est une communication
qui a une drôle d'odeur somme tout
puisqu'on est en train d'assimiler le
les étrangers à des voleurs d'emplois
américains mais c'est quelque chose qui
avait largement exploité donald trump
dans sa campagne en 2015 2016 qui avait
fortement fonctionner sur son électorat
en particulier pourquoi pas ce qu'ils
font pas oublier qu'aux états unis il ya
un certain nombre d'américains de souche
qui se trouve paupérisée depuis une
vingtaine d'années dans des situations
de sous emploi des situations de faible
revenu et qui ont permettez moi
l'expression qui ont la haine
aujourd'hui ce sont ces gens là qui ont
voté pour donald trump en 2016 et qu'ils
ont fait gagner et il le sait
pertinemment et ces gens là ne ment
jamais lâché donald trump quelles que
soient les erreurs ont en tout cas ce
qu'on a pu estimer être des erreurs de
sa part ils sont toujours derrière lui
il le soutiennent fortement et
évidemment qui jouent cette carte là
donald trump ont ils fait cette annonce
là merci beaucoup sylvie matelly d'avoir
été à parmi nous dans cette émission je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste et
directrice adjointe de l'iris l'institut
des relations internationales et
stratégiques
olivier nous on continue suit avec les
questions cash et comme à chaque semaine
olivier vous répondez aux questions que
vous posez les internautes et on
commence tout de suite avec celle de
doni décret bonjour olivier la solution
n est elle pas que les états unis et
l'europe impose une taxe coronavirus à
la chine sur ses produits plutôt que de
faire payer la crise à ses citoyens avec
augmentation d'impôts ou du temps de
travail
première chose je vous ai dit la le
coronavirus n'est que le révélateur
n'est que le détonateur d'une crise qui
est là depuis beaucoup plus longtemps
donc qu'il faudrait qu'on fasse d'abord
payer nos dirigeants avant de faire
payer les chinois donc voilà donc cessé
un peu c'est un peu ridicule la mauvaise
gestion de des différents pays fait qu'
on pourrait demander avant de demander
des détaxes en chine demander des
comptes à ceux qui nous ont mis dans
cette panade et ceux qui nous ont mis
dans cette panade ce sont nos dirigeants
se sont pas les chinois en face à la
question de marco pierre faut-il
travailler plus soit au contraire
travailler moins pour relancer
l'économie
et bien déjà il faudrait pouvoir
travailler le avant de se poser la
question de savoir s'il faut travailler
plus ou moins il va falloir que on se
pose la question de savoir comment il
faudra remettre à un moment les gens au
boulot et il leur donnait un travail
donc déjà ce n'était pas simple avant de
coronavirus ça va l'être encore moins
après et et ensuite on pourra se poser
des questions sur le temps de travail
mais je pense pas que ça soit la
première question à se poser je pense
que vraiment il faudrait que on puisse
travailler qu'on nous donne les moyens
de travailler qu'on nous envoie pas chez
nous bloquée chez nous en résidence
surveillée merci à olivier c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain numéro la semaine prochaine en
attendant n'oubliez pas de poser toutes
vos questions à olivier sur les réseaux
sociaux et puis ça
vous pouvez voir ou revoir nos
précédents numéros sur notre site
internet arte france point tv olivier on
se quitte avec le mot de la fin
la reprise n'étant une histoire que
d'alphabet je choisis le zen